[Music]
on this Thursday night it's being called
the mother of all cyber breaches the
websites hit each of the platforms is
also significant plus how to protect
yourself and are passwords
outdated Justin Trudeau's plummeting
popularity the liberal mp backtracking
on his calls for a leadership review
parents told to scrap the bubble wrap
risky doesn't mean it has to be
dangerous or bad why children can
benefit from risky
play and love conquers all how this
wedding went ahead despite the war in
Gaza as the CIA helps broker a
ceasefire global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us there's a warning tonight
from cyber Security Experts to be extra
vigilant about protecting your Digital
Data in what's believed to be the
largest breach of its kind is staggering
26 billion records have been exposed in
a leak involving multiple popular
websites tiia isri reports on what
personal information was stolen and how
you can protect yourself even in a world
of NeverEnding data breaches this one is
hard to wrap your head around it's
perhaps uh the most thorough and
comprehensive collection of uh the data
that I ever seen cyber security expert
Bob diachenko is part of the research
team that made the discovery 26 billion
leaked records a trove of stolen
information from a list of popular
platforms like LinkedIn X formerly known
as Twitter Dropbox Adobe and canva
things like usernames passwords and
emails a compilation of previous leaks
all stored together we don't know who
put it in one place uh because the owner
of the data set
was not traceable there's almost
certainly a large amount of duplicates
that explains why the number is so high
and many of the affected companies have
notified customers but having so much
information from different leaks in the
same place could allow con artists to
carry off more convincing scams more
easily it sort of allows you to build a
um uh a big profile on a user and that's
what uh I would be personally concerned
about there are ways to protect yourself
check whether you're affected using a
tool on Cyber News change your password
often and never reuse them but Canadians
are getting increasingly tired of
juggling all the logins I feel like
there's other things I'm worried about
and not so much the breach of
information because they've had our
information for so long now intimidating
and scary but it's also like to be
expected big tech companies like apple
Google and mic Microsoft are trying to
do away with passwords altogether
they're using AI to come up with new and
more secure ways to log in and keep
hackers out teria isri Global News
Ottawa the former liberal Justice
Minister David Lam has announced he's
leaving politics after eight years as an
MP the Montreal MP made the announcement
at a meeting of caucus in Ottawa saying
he's resigning with mixed emotions first
elected in 2015 the former law professor
served in a variety of parliamentary SE
secretary roles before taking over his
Justice minister in 2019 after Jody
Wilson rold resigned lametti was one of
seven ministers ousted in the last
cabinet Shuffle five have already
announced that they are leaving politics
lametti makes no reference to the
fortunes of the liberal party but anyone
who pays attention to public opinion
polls can see that if an election were
held today the Liberals would likely
lose yesterday a newfinland liberal MP
went so far as to say he believes it's
time for a leadership review he since
dialed that back Abigail Bean reports on
the tensions within the party what we
have to pay attention to and what we do
pay attention to is bringing our
community's voices to hear in
Ottawa the Prime Minister kicks off a
national Caucus meeting but paying
attention to his community's voice is
just what one New Finland MP was doing
in an exclusive interview with Radio
Canada in his writing Ken McDonald said
he's hearing a quote hatred for Justin
trudo so you think at least there should
be a leadership review in the liberal
yes let's clear the air let's you know
let's as a parity let's clear the ear
and uh if if people are still intent on
uh having the leader we have now fine
but at least give people the opportunity
to have their say barely a day later
McDonald walked it all back his
statement reads in part the intent of my
recent public comments was not to
personally call for a leadership review
and I am not calling for one now I will
continue to support my caucus colleagues
and the Prime Minister as I've done
since
2015 the party's whip won't say whether
she told him to get in line or else like
I said before we spoke but uh all
conversations with the web are private
there haven't been any other public
calls for a leadership review I have
full confidence in the Prime Minister
this is a guy who's helped get more done
for my community than in any other
government uh in my lifetime still safe
to say there are some private
frustrations within the party about the
State of Affairs we're going to do
better in the polls and things will get
better but this former liberal Chief of
Staff believes McDonald's original
comments are not indicative of a bigger
push to OU the PM that's not something
I've seen reflected in my conversations
with liberals across the country uh I
think it's an anomaly of blip uh it's
unfortunate but uh but you know Justin
Trudeau has been a strong leader of the
Liberal Party he's won three successful
campaigns back to back uh and he's
looking for a forth
takes more years a fourth with an uphill
battle Abigail Bean Global News Ottawa
the United Kingdom is hitting paws on
free trade negotiations with Canada the
next round of talks towards a permanent
bilateral trade deal was expected to
take place in less than a month the
British government now says progress is
not being made and it in its words will
only negotiate trade deals that
delivered to the British people a
statement by the Federal Trade Minister
Mary in accuses the UK of maintaining
Market access barriers for Canada's
agricultural
industry the reopened police
investigation into allegations of sexual
assault involving five former members of
Canada's world junior hockey team came
up in Ottawa today after everybody
everything was known around how Hockey
Canada conducted itself around
uh uh sexual sexual violence cases uh in
involving their players um I think it
brought the whole situation to the
Forefront and probably helped um get the
the police investigation moving that's
Canada's former sport minister in 2022
she led an investigation into Hockey
Canada's use of registration fees to
fund a $3.5 million settlement with a
young woman who alleges she was sexually
assaulted in 2018 Hockey Canada's
Federal funding was temporarily Frozen
after that five members of that 2018
team have now reportedly Been Told to
surrender to London Ontario Police in
relation to the alleged assault former
US president Donald Trump testified in
his own defense at the Civil defamation
trial in New York brought forward by
writer eege Carroll his testimony lasted
less than 5 minutes because the judge
significantly limited what the
ex-president could say in court and
warned him not to interrupt proceedings
at one point he said he' never met Carol
however he's already been found guilty
of sexually abusing and defaming her the
jury will now decide how much she should
be
awarded in Alabama tonight an inmate on
death row is about to be the first
person to be executed by a new untested
method nitrogen gas it is controversial
and potentially opens a new frontier in
how states execute death row prisoners
despite concerns from death penalty
opponents Eric senson explains why this
method is being used and why critics are
so opposed to
it a quiet vigil on the steps of Alabama
state capital calling for a last minute
stop to this evening's execution of
58-year-old Kenneth Smith three people
have been charged Smith was convicted 35
years ago after he was hired to kill a
preacher's wife critics not only oppose
his execution but are outraged by the
new method untested on humans nitrogen
hypoxia I can't think of anything as
dehumanizing is saying we're going to
use you as a human guinea pig a human
lab rat to kill you it is a morbid
subject for Kenneth Smith it's not the
first time he's been strapped to a
gurnie for execution 14 months ago
officials Tried by lethal injection and
couldn't do it properly before time was
running out on the execution warrant
this time it's using a mask forcing
Smith to breathe in nitrogen a lack of
oxygen to bring unconsciousness within
seconds and death within minutes
opponents call it nitrogen Suffocation
and some say it's unconstitutional I
think that the states that want to
execute people are thrilled you know to
see that there may be another method
here but an execution can go forward
where a corpse is created but the method
of execution or or the technique of the
execution causes an unlawful kind of
death one reason for changing from
Lethal Injections under public pressure
some drug companies sto making their
products available now one group wants
the Quebec owned us producer of the
industrial mask it believes is being
used to take similar action to try and
intervene and ensure that their products
are not used to execute Kenneth Smith
unfortunately we haven't heard anything
from them a Catholic Charity in Rome
decries both the execution and the
method a new standard of the of the
lowering level of humanity for the whole
world not just for Alabama others feared
the time was running out including
Kenneth Smith who issued a statement
asking that people not turn their heads
and normalize what is happening Smith is
SCH to be put to death this evening at
700 p.m. Eastern in Atmore Alabama Eric
senson Global News
Toronto there's another accusation of
India being behind assassinations on
foreign soil Pakistan's foreign
secretary says there's credible evidence
linking agents of the Indian government
to the killings of two Pakistani
citizens in Pakistan he claims there's
financial and forensic evidence Indian
agents assassinated two anti- India
militants in attacks on mosques in
September and October of last year
these cases reveal a growing
sophistication and brazenness of Indian
sponsored Terror terrorist acts in
Pakistan they fit the pattern of similar
cases which have come to light in other
countries including Canada and the
United States in November the US justice
department announced charges against an
Indian national for allegedly taking
part in a murder For Hire plot on us
soil and in June Canadian hard sing
nider Who advocated for an independent
six state in India shot and killed
outside a gara in Su BC prime minister
Justin Trudeau accused the Indian
government of playing a role in that
death which India has denied we're
learning more about the victims of
Tuesday's deadly plane crash in Fort
Smith Northwest Territories six people
died when the plane taking workers to a
diamond mine crashed after takeoff
Heather uck West has been speaking to
some of their loved ones First
Responders and community members
stricken with grief standing
shoulder-to-shoulder at a candlelight
vigil in morning it's touched every part
of our community you know Fort Smith is
a is a small community and everybody
knows everybody six people died when a
small plane crashed near Fort Smith on
Tuesday the Northwestern airflight had
been taking workers to the diic diamond
mine north of Yellow Knife the Rangers
who are
incredibly Hardy men uh went out there I
think by sco and uh we're hoping to be
able to save lives but they found one
Survivor and they were just grief St
they couldn't they could hardly speak
last night according to his family one
of the victims was hoe Banwell his
sister crystal says he loved playing
guitar and camping at the family cabin
he was able to light up the room with
his smile and help make others laugh she
wrote he ensured safety and inspiration
to everyone he will be greatly missed by
all Diane bowley was also killed in the
crash the longtime mind work worker also
a beloved mom she was like the sweetest
person like the kindest nicest person he
could ever you can ever meet I just
talked to her she sent me like a care
package there and we're laughing we're
joking
and and next thing you know she's gone
bostley leaves behind three children and
a grandchild one of six families now
devastated by loss Heather urick West
Global News
Calgary risk versus reward some new
advice for parents tonight coming up
like kids need to take more risks when
they
play there's some new advice for parents
back off a bit and give your kids more
freedom to play That's the the
recommendation of the Canadian Pediatric
Society it kind of takes us back to the
way childhood used to be certainly when
I grew up there was more risk less adult
supervision and this report says that's
exactly what kids need today both for
their physical and mental health it
defines risky play as playing at speed
thrilling things like biking or sledding
and Rough and Tumble play like wrestling
or fencing with sticks letting kids
explore the woods with limited or no
adult supervision depending on their age
doesn't mean removing all supervision
and safety measures just dialing back
some of the risk aversion that's so
common these days with me from Toronto
is Lee vandero who is scientific
director at participaction Lee thanks
for being with us we know that so much
of our kids lives now is regimented and
closely supervised this report kind of
flips that on its head what have kids
lost by limiting free
play Yeah by limiting the amount of time
that children have Outdoors it's really
Li limited their ability to establish
their own boundaries determine what they
view as risky play or risky engagement
and it's also decrease their ability to
just engage in overall interactive and
imaginative play and just lost that kind
of spirit of what it means to be a kid
today and this report doesn't just
Advocate more play it Advocates risky
play which means kids will push the
boundaries and test their limits and
they might get injured how can parents
draw a line between risky play and
things that are downright
hazardous absolutely so I think the
first point is you know differentiating
between hazardous versus risky play
risky doesn't mean it has to be
dangerous or bad it just means that
there has to be that ability for
children to navigate their boundaries to
establish those boundaries and those
levels of comfort it has a number of
different benefits not only in terms of
how they navigate you know on and off
the outdoor environment uh but also in
terms of building increased
self-confidence and self-esteem so as a
parent you know having these open cont
conversations and dialogue encouraging
outdoor play across a number of
different environments platforms and
surfaces and also encouraging children
you know to ask questions to thrive in
that outdoor space and not only is it
going to ensure that they're more active
healthier but it's also going to ensure
that they're inv that they're thriving
in an environment that's typically been
kind of removed for them from them in
recent times and it doesn't mean just
saying like when I was a kid go out and
I don't want to see you again till
dinner time that's not what we're
talking about here right just just
loosening up from some of the I guess
the helicopter parenting the restrictive
parenting that has been happening for
quite a few years yeah absolutely I mean
there was this shift and good reason you
know parents want to protect their
children and do everything that they can
but it has resulted in a bit of that
bubble WAP culture and so this report is
really just helping to draw attention on
steps that parents even medical
professionals other community
Specialists can take you know in terms
of helping navigate that space helping
to loosen the re while not losing focus
of this idea of overall health safety
and wellness but it's also by dispelling
some of the common myths around you know
how often our critical injuries
occurring Outdoors issues around
stranger danger and I think there's just
been a lot more hype and attention on
those particular issues but not
necessarily we're not seeing correlating
evidence that there is in fact this
increase Lee vandero thank you so much
for talking with us thanks so much for
having me take
care California rescue ahead a woman
plucked from her overturned car in the
midst of a flash
[Music]
flood this was the moment a woman was
airlifted to safety from a raging Creek
in Northern California she'd spent 15
hours on top of her submerged overturned
car after intense rain slammed the
region on Monday a camper happened to
Spotter and called for help the woman
was treated for hypothermia but is
otherwise okay Southern California is
also dealing with heavy rain a state of
emergency was declared in San Diego
which has had the wetest January on
record there are reports the head of the
US Central Intelligence Agency the CIA
will meet for talks on a possible SEI
ceasefire in Gaza and the release of
hostages William Burns is expected to
meet with the head of Israel's mad
intelligence service and Qatari
officials in Europe this Weekend Cutter
has been a key mediator and was
instrumental in brokering previous
pauses in fighting but tonight cutter is
accusing Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu of hampering efforts to secure
the release of hostages that's because a
leaked recording appeared to catch
Netanyahu criticizing
cutter in the remarks from a meeting
with hostage fams that aired on Israeli
TV Netanyahu reportedly called Cutter's
role problematic because of its Rel
relationship with Hamas K allows hamas's
military Wing to maintain a presence in
Doha and calls the comments dangerous
and
irresponsible people are
facing
deaths or risk of death because
of hunger and starvation and famine it's
not easy
to understand how hellish the situation
is that's the head of the World Health
Organization who lived through War as a
child in Ethiopia War only brings more
war and hatred he said as he called for
a ceasefire and a political solution to
Israel's war on
Hamas holding on to hope next remnants
of a regular life for
[Music]
gins
with no end in sight to the fighting in
Gaza those who are still alive live hour
by hour planning for the future is a
thing of the past for most Palestinian
families Mike Armstrong has the story of
two couples trying to find Hope where
they
can this day wasn't supposed to be like
this a young couple preparing for their
wedding but instead of at home in a
refugee camp and instead of sending out
their invit patience they burned them
for
heat the bride says they used them in a
fire in the shelter and cooked over the
Flames while she says she
cried now the conflict cost the couple
much more than just their planned
wedding date between friends who've been
killed and Friends who've been displaced
barely any of their loved ones could
attend the
ceremony she says her family is in
another camp in in another city and
moving between them is too
dangerous this is another wedding weeks
after it was supposed to happen the
couple had bought a new bedroom set for
when they were married they lost it when
their home in Gaza City was destroyed by
air
strikes the mother of the bride says she
had planned every detail with her
daughter for the big day they never
dreamt it would be in a
tent that tent the groom says was
patched together by people in the
Camp he says emotionally he's not doing
well but that the couple went through
with the wedding anyway because his
fiance deserved to feel some happiness
it is not something right now that they
feel often Mike Armstrong Global News
Montreal and that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is this Maple Leaf
at the lights at LaFarge Lake display in
kitum DC we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at Global
national.com and thanks for watching Neu
Gara will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
and I'll see you again on Monday
[Music]
bye-bye